[Musik]
guten abend und willkommen zu einem
schnellen nachrichtenüberblick in der
halbzeitpause wurde die gestern im iran
abgestürzten passagiermaschine
vielleicht versehentlich abgeschossen
von iranischen abwehrraketen
us-präsident john vermutet
möglicherweise habe jemand einen
schrecklichen fehler gemacht die boeing
737 800 der ukraine international
airlines war südlich von teheran
auf dem internationalen flughafen
gestartet nach wenigen minuten brach im
steigflug der funkkontakt ab bei dem
absturz kamen alle 176 menschen an bord
ums leben
wir fragen nach bei ines trams in
washington worauf stützt der präsident
seine these dass die maschine womöglich
aus versehen abgeschossen wurde
us satelliten so heißt es nun sollen
wohl den abschuss zweier missiles von
iran beobachtet haben kurz bevor das
flugzeug dann abgestürzt ist das kommt
zur stunde von vertretern aus dem
pentagon und von vertretern der
geheimdienste allerdings das muss man
festhalten bestätigt ist zur stunde noch
nichts und das pentagon verweigert
derzeit auch noch eine offizielle
stellungnahme wie angesprochen vor rund
einer stunde hat präsident trump tanja
vieldeutig gesagt in einer
pressekonferenz zu einem anderen thema
er könne sich vorstellen dass da etwas
ganz schreckliches passiert sein
die iranischen behörden die entgegnen
sie bleiben bei ihrer stellungnahme von
gestern verantwortlich für den absturz
sei ein technischer defekt man muss dazu
wissen die iranischen behörden
verweigern derzeit noch die black boxes
und was die black boxes über den absturz
aussagen den internationalen behörden
zur verfügung zu stellen wir haben also
im moment einen schrecklichen verdacht
aber noch keine gewissheit
dankeschön für diese informationen aus
washington - trotz im konflikt zwischen
den usa und iran gab es heute ungewohnt
persönliche zeichen der iranische
präsident mohammed stellte in aussicht
zum atom abkommen zurückzukehren
die usa sich bewegen und die usa
bekräftigten ihre absicht mit teheran in
dialog zu treten bin hier schon
berichtet
die usa sind bereit für ernsthafte
verhandlungen mit dem iran ohne
vorbedingungen so zumindest haben sie es
in einem brief an den un-sicherheitsrat
geschrieben der zur stunde tagt verbale
zeichen der entspannung solche kann man
auch beim amerikanischen vize
präsidenten heraushören
wir haben geheimdienst informationen
nach denen der iran botschaften an
befreundete milizen schickt sich nicht
gegen amerikanische ziele oder
zivilisten zu wenden
in berlin wächst bei der
verteidigungsministerin deshalb die
hoffnung die ausbildungsmission der
bundeswehr in die ragt nicht abbrechen
zu müssen
wir wollen diese missionen fortführen
aber für uns ist auch klar wir werden
dies nur tun können wenn es dazu auch
das einverständnis der irakischen
regierung gibt die ministerin
informierte die zuständigen
fachpolitiker rund 30 soldaten würden
turnusgemäß den irak verlassen die
anderen bleiben ein fehler sagt ein
großteil der opposition die
bundesregierung wird von der art der
fraktion aufgefordert alles zu tun damit
die bundeswehr innerhalb kürzester zeit
aus dem irak abziehen kann
auch der außenminister stellte sich den
fragen der abgeordneten
ganz ehrlich ich hätte mir gewünscht
dass der außenminister stadt heute ins
parlament zu kommen und zeigt uns wissen
vorzulesen jetzt stattdessen im flieger
sitzt beispielsweise nach riad um dort
zu vermitteln damit auf die mögliche
vergeltungsmaßnahme der iraner nicht
noch eine überreaktion der saudis drauf
kommt übermorgen wird heiko maas mit der
bundeskanzlerin nach moskau fliegen
der nahe osten bleibt ganz oben auf der
agenda
nach frankreich seit fünf wochen prägen
massenproteste und streiks das land der
widerstand gegen die rentenreform von
präsident marco ist nach wie vor
gewaltig heute protestierten im ganzen
land erneut hunderttausende wie hier in
paris gibt es massive behinderungen
viele metro linien fahren nicht die
regierung will unter anderem das
renteneintrittsalter von 62 auf 64 jahre
erhöhen
morgen soll es neue verhandlungen
die lage in den busch brand gebieten
australiens droht sich wieder zu
verschärfen für morgen sind starke winde
und bis zu 45 grad angesagt
polizeibeamte appellieren an die
menschen ihre häuser zu verlassen
seit beginn der wetteraufzeichnungen war
es auf dem kontinent noch nie so warm
und trocken wie im vergangenen jahr
nach expertenmeinung begünstigt der
klimawandel die seit oktober wütenden
brände donnerschlag für die briten prinz
harry und seine frau madden wollen keine
vollzeit royals mehr sein erklärten sie
gestern abend per instagram und heute
sind alle zeitungen voll damit
max it titelt etwa die sun dabei galt
das glamour-paar doch als hoffnung der
royalen familie fühlte sich aber schnell
von der presse gejagt von offiziellen
pflichten erdrückt andreas stamm über
eine entscheidung von der wohl nicht
einmal die queen musste ihr erster
termin nach der winterpause herren am
dienstag zurück in london nach sechs
wochen kanada eine kleine flucht nach
einem schwierigen jahr
24 stunden später kündigen sie die große
flucht an
völlig überraschend wir beabsichtigen
von unserer rolle als hochrangige
mitglieder der königlichen familie
zurückzutreten und arbeiten daran
finanziell unabhängig zu werden
der rest der königlichen familie sei
enttäuscht und verletzt trinkt es aus
dem palast und man stehe den plänen
skeptisch gegenüber und den
personenschutz und ihr für drei
millionen euro steuergeld renoviertes
haus will das paar weiter nutzen nur auf
einen geringen teil der bisherigen
zuwendungen verzichten heißt es auf
ihrer internetseite
obwohl royals in der zweiten reihe geld
verdienen dürfen
das ist rosinenpickerei der staat soll
ein großteil ihrer kosten übernehmen
aber sie wollen totale freiheit wenige
verpflichtungen und die möglichkeit mit
ihrer herkunft geld für ein luxus leben
zu verdienen
die gründe für den rückzug vielfältig
die kritischen boulevard medien
versuchten ihr gemeinsames leben zu
zerstören erklärte merkel jüngst was an
harrys trauma anknüpft der die presse
mit verantwortlich macht für den tod
seiner mutter diana
dazu eingezwängt in das hofprotokoll und
zu wenig normalität für sohn art
decken könnten feststellen gerade wegen
der feindlichen art der verkündung dass
die queen charles und william wenig
zugeständnisse machen
die familie wird nicht die regeln einer
tausendjährigen institution ändern
der eine teilzeit mitgliedschaft noch
nie funktioniert hat das trauma aus
prinz und ex hollywood schauspielerin
will nicht mehr richtig mitspielen im
royalen britannien ein paukenschlag
das wetter tut zumindest im grundwasser
pegel gut.de details hat gleich osten
teri hatcher slomka freut sich auf sie
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn ich
sagt tschüss und wünsche eine spannende
zweite halbzeit bis morgen wenn sie
mögen